>> Speaker 1: From the Library
of Congress in Washington DC.
>> Sally Van de Water:
Hi, good afternoon,
I'm Sally Van de Water
from the Folk Arts Program
in Pennsylvania.
It's my very great
pleasure to be here
at the American Folklife
Center and introducing
to you the founder of the
Sattriya Dance Company,
Madhusmita Bora and three of
the dancing monks of Assam.
Thank you for being
here with us.
Mandhu, I think I'd
like to start with you
and ask you, what is Sattriya?
>> Madhusmita Bora:
It's a dance tradition
from the remote northeast
corner of India,
from the state called Assam.
And it was preserved, nourished,
and created as a form of worship
in the Hindu Vishnu Monasteries.
It kind of stayed within the
Monastic walls for centuries.
And it was only in the
mid-20th century that y,
it started coming
out into the open.
And today, it is one of India's
eight classical dance form.
And that recognition
was actually recorded
in the year 20000 And since
then it has catapulted
into the proscenium stage
and you're seeing more
and more people performing
and learning the dance.
>> Sally Van de Water: How
is the dance different from,
for example, Bharatanatyam, or
Kuchipudi, or do you see some
of the other dances that
people might be familiar with.
Also, it's an unbroken tradition
of more than 500 years.
>> Madhusmita Bora: It
is a living tradition.
And this is the only dance form
that survived for centuries
as a form of oral
tradition was passed
on from one generation
of Hmong to the next.
So, that is one major
difference.
And it's a breathing,
living artform.
And there are a lot
of similarities.
And I will defer that
question to my teacher.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
>> Prerona Bhuyan: So, we
have a lot of similarities,
at the same times we have the
different see Hmong has the
different dance [inaudible]
of India.
And Sattriya, basically,
we use some elements
as what we don't see in other
dance form, the example,
we used the hand
gestures as a language.
And in then classical dance and
this dance we call language.
So separate, these hand
gestures, we use only Sattriya,
but we don't see in other
classical dance of India.
So, this is specific.
Likewise we have some
elements like we bouncing.
But we don't see in other
dance form of India.
Only we can see in
Manipuri dance.
Because Manipuri is
very near to use,
and it was the same
stays in the long times.
But after that it was separate.
So, we can see only
Manipuri dance.
So, we have a lot of difference,
then also the language.
And we use the Brazowvi
[phonic] language.
This language composed
by our great saint [foreign
name] in 15th century.
This language is what
kind of mixed language.
And he used this language as
a holy language because at
that time he has to
convince to the people,
if he used a normal language
like ordinary people
used common language,
the people don't believe that
this is one kind of holy.
So, because of that he
used a mixed language.
So, this is called
Brazowvi language.
So, in Sattriya, we
use this language.
So, we have a lot
of differences.
>> Madhusmita Bora:
Also, you know,
it's mostly Krishna worship,
we don't have too many,
I mean goddesses, when
we're telling stories.
Most of the stories
are related to Krishna.
And the principle
emotion is [foreign word].
>> Prerona Bhuyan: Yeah,
that is very important piece
in Sattriya, because Sattriya,
they take it to the devotion.
So, because of that,
yes, it was the nine kind
of [foreign word],
the sentiments.
But our ultimate
destination we have search,
we have to find the [foreign
word], this devotion.
>> Madhusmita Bora: So, yeah,
it's a very devotional artform.
Because it's part
of your worship.
And it's always, you know,
it ends with submission
to the lord and the universe.
>> Sally Van de Water:
You begin with devotion
and then there's music,
and then there's dance
and then you end with devotion.
That's lovely.
As part of today's performance,
you did your final piece was
invoking 10 the incarnations
of Krishna.
Can you talk a little
bit about how you
and your dance partner portrayed
that, how you were able to make
that come alive for the
audience through dance?
>> Madhusmita Bora: So, in our
tradition there are actually,
you know, the other
Indian classical dance,
there's also another difference,
there are 10 primary
incarnations, in ours we say 24.
But we still pick 10,
the 10 primary ones.
And you know, we
talk about them.
And the piece that we did, we
don't know who choreographed it,
but it is very, very old.
And you know [foreign
name] taught us
and that was actually
thanks to a grant
from the Pennsylvania
Council on the Arts.
So, how we did it was we
just divided our roles,
the way it was choreographed.
So, when, you know she's
portraying the fish,
I become the water.
Or when, you know,
she's a turtle head,
I'm the turtle shell, you know.
>> Sally Van de Water: Because
she's portraying Krishna,
and you're portraying
Krishna nemesis.
>> Madhusmita Bora: And
then, just because you know,
she's in a male costume.
So, that's the other interesting
aspect of this dance form.
It's very gender fluid.
Because the Hmong
dress up as women.
So, probably it is the
only dance form right now,
where women also dress
up in a man costume.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
Kuchipudi, in Kuchipudi
they do it But in Kuchipudi,
I don't know, do females
dress up as men, anymore?
I don't see that.
I know male can dress as female,
but female dressing up as men,
I think this is the only
dance form that have it?
>> Prerona Bhuyan: Yes, but
we have to think about this.
>> Madhusmita Bora: Yeah,
so that is one of you know
so because she is
always in the turban,
so she gets to play
the good guy,
and I essentially
become the bad guy.
>> Prerona Bhuyan: And we don't
say that this is the dance
of Krishna, because
we only believe
that Krishna, Krishna
[inaudible].
So, we don't believe
the other goddesses.
But yes, we believe we respect.
But we believe this is a part of
the Krishna so, because of that.
The other classical dance form,
when they dance, they dedicate
to the dance for the goddess.
We dedicate it only for Krishna.
>> Madhusmita Bora: Yeah,
Krishna is the principle deity.
And that also brings
to the other difference
you're talking about.
Our [foreign word] is called
[foreign word], it's very soft.
It's unlike the other dance form
where it's very, very rigorous.
There's the bouncing
that you see.
And that almost like the flowy
movement of the river, I think,
you know you're kind of
gliding on the stage,
rather than standing and making.
>> Sally Van de Water: Well,
it's incredibly elegant
and fluid, yes.
Absolutely.
>> Prerona Bhuyan:
Yes, because we believe
that it is the [inaudible]
to a heart for mother earth.
So, because of that we bounce.
>> Madhusmita Bora: Whereas,
the other dance form, the bow
and then they stamp on the
mother earth [laughter].
>> Sally Van de Water:
Well, I think,
you know it's really remarkable
that Sattriya has more
than 500 years of unbroken
tradition that's always been
carried on in the
monastery except
in the last, say 20 years or so.
Women are now also
doing this as well.
Can you talk a little
bit more about that,
you're one of the
first women to do?
>> Madhusmita Bora: No,
I'm not one of the first.
>> Sally Van de Water:
Oh, you're not.
Okay, sorry.
>> Madhusmita Bora: So,
actually probably 1960s.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
Probavly 1960, but it was not,
you know, it was not very,
for the lack of a better
word, it was not very cool.
There was not enough funding.
And there were other dance,
classical art forms that were
so vibrant at that
time, even in Assam.
Like [inaudible].
So, people were more
drawn toward that.
You know,
so there were like two,
three practitioners,
but not very many.
The access to the
artform was also hard.
Because most of the Hmong
were not allowed to teach.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
So, you know one of my
teachers [foreign name] was,
I mean he nearly
got excommunicated
because he ventured out
to teach at that point.
You know, this was in the 1980s.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
So, he also wanted to
like teach outside.
But it was, you know
there was this resistance,
because the older monks wanted
to preserve the tradition,
and to let go was
really , really hard.
But I think since
2000, it has become.
You know it has become
more accessible.
A lot of things have happened.
Of course, India has
progressed by leaps and bounds.
Transportation is easier,
the island is more
accessible to go and learn.
And then, you know there are
practitioners like Bhabananda
who are actually moving
out and like, you know,
staying in the cities and
teaching students from all over.
>> Prerona Bhuyan: But I think,
this is my personal view,
that the [inaudible] it not mean
the [inaudible] didn't allow.
It means the outsiders
not interested about this.
So, when the outsider
interest to know about this,
that's first of most often.
Because the should trust
people outside and they teach
for the women insiders.
So, I think that outsider
was not interested before.
So, when the outsiders
get interested about this,
the [inaudible] people, they
wanted to give them these.
>> Madhusmita Bora: So, yeah,
it was more like access.
You know there was no access.
So, yeah that must
have brought them yeah.
>> Sally Van de Water:
Absolutely.
Can I ask you, Mr. [inaudible]
how has it been to work
with Madhu, you've been
her apprenticeship teacher
for a couple of years now?
How has that been for you
to have a student in
the United States.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
>> Madhusmita Bora: So, both
of them actually I trained
under both of them
around the same time,
so they can both
talk about that.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
So, he says when he
first joined the.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
When he was five, most of them,
Barbayan is seventh generation
Hmong from his family.
He is third.
So, most of them came and
they joined the monastery
when they were five
or six years old.
And so, you know he learned
the music and the arts,
and he really wanted
to teach it.
And teach the philosophy of
the great teacher to outsiders.
That was, you know he really
had that passion for that.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
So, you know he really
wanted to teach outsiders,
but at that point,
they were forbidden
to teach outside the monastery.
But he had, you know he believed
that he was in the right.
So, he kind of you know,
overcame all sorts of obstacles.
And he started teaching.
Because he really believed
that you know, it was important
to spread the message,
and the philosophy
of the great teacher,
and his arts.
So, that it would someday be
presented on the world stage.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
So, you know, he said
basically, so when I went there,
I first went to the
[foreign word],
I do believe I should
translate correctly.
The head of the monastery,
right?
You know, and that's what I did
because I didn't
know where to go.
So, I went to the
head of the monastery.
And then, he kind of took
me to meet Bhabananda.
But he was busy there
was a documentary filming
that was going on, so he told
me you have to wait for an hour.
And then, you know after waiting
around when I finally met
with him, he said; you know,
I told him that I wanted
to learn the dance form.
And you know, he said
he was very happy
because he likes teaching
and then he knew I
had come from so far.
So, he happily took
me under his wings.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
So, it was in 2002,
he's getting emotional.
So, this was in 2002 when
you know we started talking.
And then, you know we would
always have these discussions.
And I always said I
wanted to bring them here,
and he would say, yeah can
we all go and maybe someday;
because they have never
been to the United States.
And he said, you know maybe
somehow you can arrange it.
And you know we knew it
was a Herculean task.
Because bringing
a group of people
when you know the funding,
it is very expensive.
And, but you know
he always believed.
I mean he would always say, it
will happen, it will happen.
And I also had this crazy dream.
So, he said he is so
happy to be here today.
He is overcome with emotions,
because this has been,
you know we've talked about
this since the early 2000s
and it's happening and
it's like really unreal.
>> Sally Van de Water: Well,
it's really a very
great honor, thank you.
We're very honored to have you
here in this magnificent space.
Thank you, I hope that you
have a wonderful time here
in the United States.
Thank you.
I have a blank moment now.
What else do you
think is important?
What else is important for
you that we record with.
Do you want to ask
[inaudible] about?
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
>> Madhusmita Bora: So,
he was five years old
when he joined the
[foreign word].
And they're cousins.
And they're both National
Award winners, both of them.
So, you know and for 18
years he trained vigorously
in the artform because he
lived in the monastery.
But this was, you know prior
to Hotchia [phonic]
becoming a classical artform.
He really wanted to study
another classical dance form
to bring those rigors
into his movement.
So, he left the monastery in
pursuit of studies and trained
in another dance
form for two years,
but he doesn't perform
it or teach it.
It was just for his own
understanding, and you know,
studying Hotchia as
a classical artform.
And then, because he was
originally from the monastery.
So, there are a lot of,
they have to live a
very disciplined life.
It is hard.
Bhabananda manages.
I don't know how.
But it is very, very hard.
So, when he was there, you
know he started living,
and now he's a family man.
He kind of left the order.
And for me, again the access
to Madgule has always been an
issue, because it is you know,
you have to travel by boat.
When the river is in
state, it's really,
really hard to get there.
So, I was also looking for
alternatives in the city.
So, I would divide my time.
I could only go to Madgule for
some time, and then when I'm
in the city, where my
parents are right now.
And [inaudible] kind
of lives there.
And again, the head of the
monastery connected us and said,
you know when you're in
town, in your hometown,
you can study under him.
So, that's how we did it.
>> Sally Van de Water:
Tell me more about Assam.
You grew up there.
And you grew up in the
town and how far is
that from Madgule
from the monastery?
The town?
>> Madhusmita Bora:
It is pretty far.
So, I was born in a
small down called Dispur
and then I was raised mostly
in my father's village it's
called Madhcal [phonic].
And it's interesting because
Madhcal is kind of a seat of art
and culture, so I
grew up like listening
to the rhythms of
you know Hotchia.
My aunts and uncles
trained in it.
and we have this
unbroken tradition
which is hundred-something
years old.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
That happens in my village.
So, all my cousins.
I mean it happened this year,
and I was supposed to perform,
but I couldn't make it.
My uncles, my extended
family were always involved
in [foreign word].
So, you know it was kind of
second nature almost to kind
of get immersed in the arts.
But Madgule is pretty
far from there and then,
I had to pursue my
education and at that time,
Assam was in a very
turbulent state.
You know, we had a
secessionist outfit.
So, it was not a very safe
place for most people.
So, my parents kind of
encouraged me to leave the state
and go outside for my high
school and my college.
And that's what I did.
So, you know there was,
I learned under a teacher
in my hometown for
a little while,
and then that connection
was snapped because.
Yeah. And that was, and I
was four or five years old,
until about seven years of age.
Then I left Dispur
and I left [inaudible]
and I kind of grew up in Delhi.
And there was no, you
know I didn't have access
to anybody then.
So, I went to the next best
alternative, which was Kathak.
So, I trained in Kathak
for about 16 years.
But what was interesting
was my Kathak teacher,
Janet Kadidi [assumed spelling],
who lives in New York.
And she has trained under
one of the luminaries,
a living legend [inaudible].
And I joined her dance company.
So, I was part of
the Kathak Ensemble
and Friends in New York.
And it was very interesting
because in doing choreographies,
or when I'm dancing, and
she would say, you're lost,
she'll always say, there's
some sadness in your movement.
And where did you get this from.
And it was my muscle memory.
So, even though I was one of
the senior most performers
in her group, you know
one day she just said,
child you need to go.
You need to go back, and
you know follow your heart,
this is not where your heart is.
And I think, you know
even to this day for me,
like she is my ultimate
teacher, because she let go.
And she said, just go, and
follow your dreams, you know
and pursue your passion.
So, that's how I actually
ended up in the monastery
when I met [inaudible]
the first time.
And then, you know I realized
because it's so precious
and it's of course, you know
there was this deep connection.
It was very easy
to get back to it.
And I let go of Kathak even
after 16 years of training,
I gave away my bells,
all my costumes,
because I didn't want any kind
of you know alteration
of what I'm doing.
Because this is my
heritage and I would
like to preserve it the way, and
you know accord it the respect
and sanctity that it deserves.
>> Sally Van de Water:
That's wonderful.
I know you've got
a lot of support
from the P Foundation and.
>> Madhusmita Bora:
Absolutely, I've been so lucky
that you know, I
mean two PCA grants,
three Levy Foundation
grants and in one of,
the second Levy Foundation grant
Bhabananda was in the monastery
and that's how, I was
working on this project, yeah.
So, you know so Bhabananda kind
of helped me document all the
basic grammar of the dance form.
And Pew, I mean Pew
is unbelievable.
You know, I just in my wildest
dreams did not think it was
going to happen.
And here we are you know
after a year of like,
it feels like I have done a
PhD in the last year or two.
But you know I'm so
grateful for the support.
And yes Pew is you know very
generous with their grant,
but leading up to it, you know
if I wouldn't have
had the support Levy,
or from Pennsylvania
Council on the Arts,
I don't think I'd
be where I am today.
Because it's a very lonely ride.
You know, since I'm the
only one practicing it here
and that access to the teachers
and to the nerve center is
so important and without
funding and support,
you know I wouldn't
have been able
to do what I'm doing right now.
>> Sally Van de Water:
I really want
to ask you a little
bit more about that.
You are the only
practitioner here
in the United States doing this
artform, and it's usually done
in the context of a
group, a larger group
such as at the monastery.
How do you negotiate that?
How do you?
What's your daily practice like?
What do you do to keep
the traditional alive
in your own life?
>> Madhusmita Bora: I feel
like, you know for most of us,
it becomes; it's the
nature of the artform.
It is actually a way of life.
It's a way of life.
For them, of course, I mean
this is, they live, breathe
and you know this
is what they do.
But even for other
practitioners,
I think it becomes
your life's philosophy.
And it is hard like
to be the only person.
But I've been very blessed
because my dance partner
and you know the cofounder
of the dance company
is my sister-in-law.
Which is just, you
know was wonderful.
That's very convenient.
And she travels here quite
frequently whenever we have
shows, big shows.
And we dance together,
even in India,
or last year we performed
in London.
It is hard, because it is
essentially a community worship
which they can do.
I mean we cannot
create that music,
you know I mean this
is very special.
So, the first time that we're
doing it with live musicians,
you know, yeah, I mean here.
You know, because I don't
have access to that.
So, this was very, very special
because we're always
dancing to recorded music.
So, even though, yes, you know
your philosophical and it's
such a spiritual artform, and
you're in it and you're in it
and you're you know, every
movement is sort of an offering
to the universe and to the Lord.
But like, it's not the same when
you don't have the community.
You know. So, it
is very special.
But like, to keep
it going, again,
it's because I think it's
the passion that drives it.
It's also like you know these
are the stories and you feel
that burden to kind of carry
on these stories forward
and leave it for
the next generation.
For me, it's my son.
You know, that's his
connection to his roots.
So, that's what drives
me, I guess.
>> Sally Van de Water:
Does he dance?
>> Madhusmita Bora: No,
he doesn't [laughter].
But he's really into
all the stories.
So, yeah.
>> Sally Van de Water:
Well, thank you.
We're so honored
to have you here.
Thank you again, thank you
for traveling such a long way.
Is there anything
else that you would
like to say, or like to add?
>> Madhusmita Bora: So,
what we're really excited
about you know is the Pew
Grant is funding this project,
which is called the
Threads of History,
Resurrection of the Textile.
So, this is you know a part
of tapestry that I discovered
in the Philadelphia
Museum of Art,
which was actually in storage.
And on the trip when I met
Barbayan and [inaudible]
and we were documenting
the grammar of the artform
through my Levy Grant was when
he mentioned about, he said,
you know there is a possibility,
that you know this
tapestry exists.
So, I was on a wild goose chase,
through because I didn't know
how to ask them what it was,
because I mean if I say [foreign
word] they had no idea what
it was.
So, it took about
almost 2, 3 years
and by then the museum
had gotten funding
to digitize their collection.
So, one night I was looking
through their digital archives
and I came across it and it was
called the clothe of Vrindavan.
So, immediately, I was so
excited and I kind of called him
and sent him the
pictures and I said,
is this what we were
looking for.
And he said, yes that's it.
You know, incredible I know.
So, then I wrote the curators.
But unfortunately the south
Asia was under renovation.
So, she said, you know two
months and then you can come
and see it and that's when
you can photograph it.
So, it was a long two months.
And I went in and
then that moment
when I first saw it was
really unbelievable, you know.
We took pictures.
I sent it to them, and
then you know that's
who we started working on it.
And then, the Philadelphia
Folk Art Project actually,
who have also supported my
work and then they said,
why don't you go and talk
to the Pew, this is totally,
like it has Pew written
all over it right?
So, the next call was to Pew
and they invited me to apply.
And so, it's finally
coming together.
So, Barbayan has been
traveling to different parts.
So, he has done a translation
of the textiles in London,
at the British Museum
and in Paris.
So, this is his third.
So, we are calling it the
Journey of [foreign word].
And it's happening
you know Saturday,
April 21st at the
Philadelphia Museum of Art.
They're hanging the
tapestry, I'm so excited
about this, in the auditorium.
And you know, I'm presenting
them, I'm not dancing,
because this is their
pilgrimage.
And they will be basically
just bringing the cloth to life
through their movements
and telling the stories
from the cloth.
>> Sally Van de Water:
That's wonderful.
Please tell us more
about this textile.
Does the textile
depict the stories
that you're also
embodying through dance?
Can you tell us more?
>> Prerona Bhuyan:
These textiles woven
under the guidance
of the great saint,
[foreign name] in
the 15th century.
So, were depicted the
story of the Krishna.
Yeah. So, we wanted to reveal
this through out artform.
So, it was in 2008 when
we first visit in Paris,
the times we had first
to visit the textile.
So, the net year 2009, that's
when I visit again in Paris
at that time some ideas come
out if we can do
something on that textile.
So, after we had discussed
with professor of university.
Then, said yes you
can do something.
So at that time start it and in
2011 I was there in nine months
for only for the
study of the textile.
Then, so I choreographed one
drama based on the textile.
Then Sattriya to produce.
So, subsequently we again,
we did afford the [inaudible]
on the basis on [inaudible]
and it was in 2016.
But this is our third one, then
headed by her because we thanks
to Madhusmita because
she support us,
and she give confidence of dance
and so we are able
to do because of her.
>> Madhusmita Bora: But I
wouldn't be here if it wasn't.
So, it's a wonderful circle.
But the presentation in
the textile is you know 15
to 16th century they're
saying, we can't date it
and what's interesting was these
textiles were all mislabeled.
So, there are some that appeared
from India and they were all
in Tibet and from Tibet they
went to different parts there.
They're now saying
there are like 15 pieces
of these textiles, there's only
one piece available in India,
in a museum in [inaudible] and
the rest are dispersed all over.
Ours is the third piece
that they are going
to be bringing to life.
>> Sally Van de Water:
Are they identical pieces?
Or are they all?
>> Madhusmita Bora: No, they all
have stories from Krishna's life
from the time of
his birth to death.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
>> Prerona Bhuyan: According
to the ancient scripture,
there's other, those textiles
that depicted only the story
of Krishna back to the
death of his maternal uncle.
But in particular when we
see the different places what
discovered, there we can see
the story of [foreign word] too.
So, the scholars,
they're going to say
that maybe it's not
original piece,
maybe this is not
continuation of the tradition,
that they made this
kind of piece it was
for the [foreign word].
>> Madhusmita Bora:
Yeah, the scriptures,
you know you cover,
it's like yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
>> Sally Van de Water: How
large are the textiles?
>> Madhusmita Bora: The one
in the Philadelphia Museum is
about is it about 6 feet?
Yeah. Long and I cannot
remember the measurements.
It's this broad, yeah and that
one has all stories of Krishna
in it and it's woven
in you know strips.
And it kind of continues.
Like it's the four
scenes and then the four.
So, you know we kind
of decode it.
So, they'll be using masks.
And they'll be using masks.
And they'll be doing it as
a dance drama tradition.
And so, you saw some of it.
The [inaudible] dance
that he did today,
the storyteller's dance
and he'll be doing
that even in the museum.
Telling the story.
Yeah. But you know the
Philadelphia Museum piece was
actually brought into
Philadelphia in early 1990s,
and what is really amazing is
Phillis Blum [assumed spelling]
who is the creator of textiles
who purchased the
cloth is still there.
So, she will be sitting
on the panel.
Yeah. And she didn't
know what it was.
Like, she just thought it
was this amazing fabric.
And it just spoke to her, so
she bought it at an auction.
And so, when I approached
them, they were like, wow.
You know like they didn't know.
>> Sally Van de Water: That's
so amazing that you can give
that much context to the piece.
>> Madhusmita Bora: Yeah, yeah.
So, we've been able through
the Pew Fund we were able
to also create this documentary,
and this is the second
or third time that the
text will be on display
in the South Asian Gallery.
And they're planning to have
it up for the next six months.
And some of you know
the documentation I did
in the monastery will be played
along in a panel on a loop.
So, that's very exciting.
Thank you.
>> Sally Van de Water:
Very exciting.
Congratulations,
that's wonderful.
Well thank you so much.
Thank you all this
was really incredible.
Thank you.
>> Madhusmita Bora: Thank you.
>> Sally Van de Water:
Thank you for being here.
>> Madhusmita Bora: Thank you.
>> Speaker 1: This
is the presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.